هذا المشاهدين حرب اوكرانيا عززت موقع
ودور قوات فاجن الروسيه امام الداخل
الروسي وطبعا ايضا امام خارجه سماحه الحرب
بالكشف لاول مره عن هويتها الرسميه ووجه
مؤسسها
بعد سنوات من نفي روسي ولكن بعد تمرد
فاغنر وانسحابها من مدينه روستوف الروسيه
اين كانت تتمركز هذه القوات في الشرق
الاوكراني سنقول بان هذه القوات او محور
الحرب بين الجيشين الاوكراني والروسي هي
مدينه بخمه الاستراتيجيه هي طبعا حقيقه
شغلت حيزا كبيرا من يوميات الحرب في
اوكرانيا وخاضت فيها فاجنر اشرس المعارك
على مدار ثمانيه اشهر لتعلن بعدها السيطره
عليها ولتسلمها للجيش الروسي في 25 من
مايو الماضي ايضا كانت تتواجد قوات فاغنر
في منطقه ز جنوب اوكرانيا حيث تدور معارك
طاحنه بين الجيش الروسي والاوكراني تحديدا
هنا نتابع
وتحديدا بعد ان بدات كياف هجومها المضاده
في جنوب دونيتسك ايضا هناك تمركز مهم
لقوات فاغنر حيث يشتعل في هذا المحور قتال
عنيف على كافه الجبهات البريه والجويه ذهب
ضحيتها مئات الضحايا طبعا من الطرفين اما
عدد قوات فاجنر في الشرق الاوكراني فيقدر
بحوالي 25 الفا فيما تقول وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان عددهم لا يتجاوز 8000 لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات